[موسيقى]
نحن الان في منفذ عرجيل اخر نقطه الحدوديه
لعبور المصريين والسودانيين والرعايه
الاجانب الذين يهربون من جحيم ما يحدث في
السودان الى مصر
الضرب
والقاف الخرطوم والضرب بيقع عشوائي بقى
الضرب يعني
حد صالح حرج
ة لحد ما وصلنا القاهره في امان الله
[موسيقى]
متدهور شديد
وضحايا شديد
والغنابل بتقع في خشم الباب
ونهب مسلح بصوره عشوائيه احنا دلوقتي جينا
وبيوتنا مش معروفه حنلقاها ولا مش حنلقاز
[موسيقى]
ومن خلال هذه الحافلات سينتقلون الى
وجهتهم المقبله مدينه اسوان التي تبعد عن
هذا المنفذ حدودي 500 كلم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات